alexis poulain co fondateur du journal
le monde moderne et philippe pascot
écrivain et ancien maire adjoint de
manuel valls à evry bonsoir à tous les
deux merci d'être en direct pour cette
soirée spéciale second tour des
élections municipales alexis poulain une
ré une question pour vous pour commencer
aurait-on dû maintenir en tout cas ce
second tour at-il il a lieu et est ce
une bonne chose selon vous c'est une
bonne chose dans le sens où la vème
république touche à sa fin c'est un
simulacre de démocratie le premier tour
l'a été le deuxième tour l'est encore
plus on peut pas se satisfaire de ce
taux d'abstention c'est pas juste c'est
pas normal c'est pas sain et et on ne
peut pas se satisfaire de disques ou
voix près les élus vont dire qu'ils ont
été élus que finalement ça fait
légitimité et qu'on va pouvoir repartir
pour cinq ans un peu comme l'a fait et
noël mâcon lors de son élection en 2017
ça veut dire qu'on est avec vous on va
continuer d'en parler avec vous il
semblerait que louis aliot va prendre la
parole dans quelques instants on a pas
que sont pour le moment excusez-moi
alexis poulain je vous laisse poursuivre
donc voilà on ne peut pas se satisfaire
de ce simulacre de démocratie
tout simplement parce que les gens ne
comprennent pas pourquoi ils votent ne
votent pas l'abstention c'est un mal
profond alors soit on revoit totalement
les modes de scrutin et dans ce cas là
on pourra appeler sa démocratie soit on
arrête tout de suite et on change de
régime mais on ne peut pas avoir un
président qui est élu tous les cinq ans
par défaut avec une base à 25% et qui
fait ce qu'il veut pendant cinq ans
façon roi soleil miniature donc ça ne
satisfait pas la majorité des français
je pense alors ça satisfait les fans de
celui qui est élu
mais on voit bien qu'il ya un malaise
profond dans notre pays que ce soit les
gilet jaune depuis deux ans les
manifestations soignant les policiers
maintenant les professeurs et tous les
autres qui sont dans la rue pour dire ça
suffit
en fait nous nous souhaiterions être
entendu le grand débat était un
simulacre ces municipales sont encore un
simulacre
bravo à ceux qui ont été élus mais
malheureusement on ne peut pas appeler
ça des élections n'ont pas cessé pour
moi
un dernier théâtre d'un régime qui
atteint le bout de souffle et c'est pas
pour rien que les gilets jaunes
demandaient le référendum d'initiative
citoyenne qu'il y avait une volonté en
fait il ya une envie dans ce pays de
réhabiliter la démocratie le
gouvernement du peuple par le peuple
pour le peuple de refaire république
autrement et je crois que si on continue
comme ça c'est deux ans de 290 mâ demel
macron vont être extrêmement pénible
extrêmement longues à remaniement avec à
nouveau des artistes capables de dire
tout et n'importe quoi pour avoir un
poste de ministre dévoile à ces
élections municipales qui sont alors
c'est le comédien s'est pas c'est la
faute à personne mais fallait-il les
maintenir
je pense que compte tenu de ce qui a été
le premier tour s'était pas forcément
une bonne idée mais il fallait bien sûr
mettre des collèges municipaux avoir de
deux nouvelles équipes pour faire
avancer les villes et les territoires
est ce que c'est la bonne façon de faire
ça permet de masquer aussi une gifle
électorale massive pour la majorité qui
est balayée dans ces municipales sa
fausse complètement tout d'une certaine
façon et mais c'est une sortie facile
pour éviter de dire que ben oui si agnès
buzyn perdu à paris c'est pas de sa
faute c'est le combiné si la majorité se
prend une claque c'est pas de sa faute
non plus mais je crois que ce simulacre
là moi je commence à me fatiguer en tant
que commentateur en tant que lecteur en
tant que citoyen tout simplement j'ai
envie d'autre chose je pense que à
partir du moment où on en arrive là
avec un taux de participation si faible
il faut revoir totalement la façon dont
on fait les scrutins la façon dont on
engage aussi les campagnes cette
campagne elle n'a pas eu lieu
c'était une campagne fantôme on ne
pouvait pas faire campagne avec ou sans
les masses qu'enfin cesse et c'est
impossible en fait de mobiliser et des
équipes et les gens alors les équipes se
sont mobilisées bravo à ceux qui ont été
élus bravo à tous ceux qui ont fait le
travail mais honnêtement je vois pas
comment on peut se satisfaire d'être
élue ce soir dans des conditions
pareilles merci à alexis poulain je
rappelle que vous êtes co fondateur du
journal le
monde moderne